Now that you have a good grasp of the strength and direction of linear
relationships, we need a way to quantify these characteristics. The number that
quantifies the relationship is called the correlation coefficient, denoted by
r. You have seen r before when we did t-tests. This is also known as Pearson's
r, named after a statistician as usual. We will describe the formula so that
you know what it is, and we'll focus on interpreting r. r is a fraction just
like many of our other statistics. The numerator is the covariance of x and y.
This is a function. This does not mean Cov or some number times x, y. This is
the covariance of x and y which is in itself a statistic for how much x and y
co vary, in other words how much they vary together. In the demoninator is the
standard deviation of x times the standard deviation of y. And this describes
how the two variables vary apart from each other rather than with each other.
Another way of writing it is like this. Even though r is a ratio, it's not
interpreted as a percentage. However, r squared is the percentage of the
variation in y explained by the variation in x. You saw this before when we did
t-tests, and you saw how we explained a certain percentage of the difference
between sample means, or between a sample mean and the population mean, that's
due to the different treatments. r squared here has the same interpretation. r
squared is called the coefficient of determination. r measures the strength of
a relationship, by looking at how closely the data falls along a straight line.
If it falls perfectly along a straight line in the positive direction, then r
is positive 1. And if the data fall perfectly along a straight line in the
negative direction, r is negative 1. Data that are not correlated at all have a
correlation coefficient of zero. Usually data will not fall along a straight
line, but sometimes it comes pretty close. And then r in this case might have a
correlation coefficient of 0.8, which is actually pretty high.